um are you like a big uh are you like a
big LSU football guy yeah yeah what do
you think that the quarterback supposed
to be like a top five pick did you watch
football this year yeah what's Southern
college football's different bro like
y'all treat that [__] like it's [__]
like religion bro yeah I mean LSU is in
my hood so I'm just like isn't it really
like religion type level dedication like
when it comes to like the LSUS of the
world and the Auburn and the Alabama CR
like these like man y'all are crazy bro
yeah I don't know it's different and
then it's so funny to me cuz I always
see these videos of like Southern
College football fans that are obviously
racist unless it's Saturday yeah and
then they got to root for the black
players yeah no like I'm out tripping
right that's a lot of them can't stand
black people then except on Sat on
football day what's up hey what's up man
run B
run no that's funny what else what else
you doing these days just to like like
extra like if are you watching TV
playing video games what are you doing
in your spare time video games this been
my like just ease my mind type of time
been playing a lot of MLB really the
show yeah I haven't played the show in
like I was playing GTA and stuff but
it's played it [__] my computer up I
had to get a new computer oh you're on
the computer you're on the PC yeah RP or
you do the role play yeah in Grizzly
World oh you're in Grizzly World yeah
well I haven't been like 3 months I'm
about to get back in for people who
don't know T Grizzly has a the biggest
server fire and if you're in the game
you have to it's like acting you can't
be you can't be yourself you can't break
character you can't break your character
so if you broke character in Grizzly
World what happens I think you get like
a war you get suspended do they shoot
you no if you break CED you just like
like it'll kick kick you out so what's
your character in Grizzly World I got
two I got one that's my name he like a
do de and stuff like that in the streets
and then I got other one called like
officer BR stupid oh so you're a cop
yeah so you're just [__] with people
I hold [__] with
people officer bruss stupid yeah so you
just pull it over and like do you have
an accent
like what's the BR stupid accent give it
to me hey loser I got a drugs that you
wanted
you you pull up some clips
on YouTube yeah yeah yeah do they know
it's you some people know that like the
fans that watch my my TW my my uh Twi
stuff yeah oh so you're you're twitching
hard I was I slowed down a lot were you
getting money off of that yeah I ain't
never really seen those crazy most I
seen like $2,000 so I just really be
doing it for fun for fun that's so funny
when you do something like that does it
make you realize like damn I could
[__] act for real you know what I'm
saying like if I really needed to I I
could play I could play all kind of no
because once like cuz I be bust out
laughing I had to mute my mic and just
bust out laughing oh for sure I couldn't
do it bro I because I I see some of like
like T Grizzly like they'll be doing
this like serious drug deal and [__] and
the way they be talking to each other
I'm like this [__]
is man I've only played story mode on
Grand Theft Auto I've never played
online no it's fun story mode I I beat
that [__] like 10 years ago you know
what I'm saying I can't wait for the new
one yeah six is coming soon so right now
you're on MLB yeah
Otani the Asian man no he ain't on my he
ain't on my team but I Fu with Otani
though he's a Dodger now yeah I was
hoping he came to Miami yeah the shout
outs of the Marlins I don't know if
they're good or not I don't really no
they're good they got a nice Squad well
my team's uh need to upd they pitch and
roster a little bit I'm from Arizona so
the diamond just made it into the World
Series which made me care about baseball
for about two weeks yeah you know I
don't give a [__] about baseball are you
are is that your that's not your
favorite sport is it is it yeah baseball
is
yeah I played oh you played what' you
play uh shortstop mainly shortstop is
you gotta be on it yeah yeah were you
like how far did you go uh I had St High
School I could have I could have did
some in college but I went a whole
different why do you think there aren't
more um I feel like the best baseball
players come from everywhere else but
here oh like I feel like there's not a
lot of like like when we think of like
uh High School BAS bball High School
football it's like a thing but I feel
like baseball for whatever reason it's a
lot harder to get the youth involved why
do you think that is like what got you
into it like no I when I was little some
friends yeah but baseball is
real more it's a lot more mental and you
got to really be like it's you got to be
super dedicated to be good at it right
you know what I'm
saying uh and it's a sport where okay
like football if you run the play okay
the catcher got to get to you I mean the
the the quarterback yeah the center got
to get the ball the quarter back and run
you got help to to win a game baseball
just you baseball when you go up there
that ball come to you you got to catch
and throw that [__] you feel me
y you go up the bat you got to hit the
ball or not hit the ball you feel me so
that's what everybody says about golf
like golf is like golf is [__] born
see I've never played I couldn't do it
I've only played a top golf in Vegas
where you hit the ball and [__] but my
homies are in the golf and they're like
it's it's like you versus yourself mhm
it's all it is you're you're against the
course who cares if you're playing
somebody like it's really the whole game
is just it's like mental
like fortitude I don't they could keep
golf it's definitely boring that's crazy
baseball huh so is your your team is the
Marlins u i f with the Marlins I got a p
on the Marlins
uh I wouldn't say nobody else is my
favorite cuz I'm more of a like I I'm a
fan of a person like so so who's your
favorite player
Manny Ramirez my favorite all but him
you know he Manny was a beast on the Red
Sox so you were [__] with the Red Sox
10 yeah and then we went to the Dodgers
he went to the Dodgers yeah so right now
it's like otani's the guy yeah he nice
it's crazy cuz he I I feel like he's
been the only person since like Babe
Ruth that's been good as good at hitting
as he is as pitching cuz back in the day
Babe Ruth was a pitcher on the on the
Red Sox before he went to the Yankees
yeah uh CE CeCe saath was good hitter
too I don't remember shout out to CC I
remember CC I didn't know he was hitting
though I didn't know he was hitting yeah
see he I don't think he ain't get as
many bets Bay Area Legend right there CC
sebastia shout out to him well T is a a
different crazy and he got the bag and
he got paid smart yeah he kicked all cuz
you know in La the taxes suck so he's
only getting paid $2 million a year and
then after his Deal's over is when all
the real money kicks in and he'll be
[__] he'll we left La by then H at
tax money in C's you doing the right
thing Florida's where it's at no state
tax you could carry a gun you know what
I'm saying you could do whatever you go
to a strip club at 6:00 in the morning
get some chicken wings Mar probably just
ain't have enough in him yeah what is do
you have a a favorite Miami strip club
you like I've been to most of them I
mean booby trap booby trap is cool it's
just a lot I'm just not a club it's just
a lot going on there I like I like thato
there a lot going on in Miami period I
like tootsies though TOS tootsies is
just chill you could go sit off in the
cut and have a lobster tail and not be
bothered be so too sedi you get up on
that second floor got security running
around the parking lot harassing you and
[__] yeah booby traps a wild Place yeah
booby trap's fun well I'm just not a
club person I just I'd rather be in the
house playing video games unless you're
getting paid to be there yeah and Anime
what's your favorite
anime my all time favorite in
Yasha but I've been locked in to uh
Black Clover I've been locked in my hero
Academia I've been locked in to uh the
new bleach bleach yeah I've heard of
that my son I just bought my son the
sword from uh one piece I bought him a
sword
from I'll tell you right now cuz I
texted him what's your favorite
anime I bought him I spent like 200 on
Christmas I brought him this [__]
sword from this [__] anime a saw yeah
it's a
um Attack on Titan oh Attack on Titan it
was good I can't stand how it ended it
was [__] he says his favorite character
is amond and my top anime is Dragon Ball
nuto and Attack on Titan dragon ball one
of my tops too they just don't be
consistent no more isn't there like 30
Seasons how do you like I you know what
is is but you gotta think all the
episodes be stretched to like like one
fight of be Eight Episodes see I didn't
know that yeah you know what is in anime
people don't give credit for it being in
anime is The
Boondocks it's not an anime it is it's
not it is it's not see that's it is an
anime it's I mean if you go off the
anime definition it's not what does that
mean it's like Chinese animation it's
Japanese I think no it's not is it
Chinese wound was made by uh Aaron
mcgruer but it's it's it was made
very you've never seen the fights in the
Boondocks that's not anime it's an anime
bro The Boondocks is an anime just like
Afro samai Samurai in anime so if I call
car he G he gonna say his feel like his
anime yeah Aaron first of all the guy
who created his name is Aaron
mcgruer you like you like The Boondocks
I love The Boondocks I got all seasons
on DVD me too season 3 was that was when
the writers left I love all love season
one and two though I don't think it gets
better I got a radio drop from uh Uncle
Ruckus for real yeah the voice actor was
doing drops yeah like 10 years ago I got
it shout out to Uncle Ruckus AKA is it
safe to say would you say the closest
thing to like a real life Uncle Ruckus
we've seen is chareston
white I'm not sure it's
close right he said some crazy [__]
about his own people I'm just like that
very I was a little uncor
rucky you might be right you got the
eyes [__] that St he said he got the ey
no offense but you know no but he does
he does have the I didn't even you know
what I wasn't even thinking about
that I think he really be just doing
that for the social media I don't know
what I've seen I met him before was he
nice yeah I mean listen I've seen a lot
of his content that I think is hilarious
and I've seen a lot of his content that
I think is yeah extremely
yeah when I met him I just told him I
like I don't agree with what you be
saying but you say what you want so you
know right